this morning on the dish a true taste of
Italy from award-winning writer and
cookbook author Stacey at E mondo born
in Connecticut to an Italian American
family she went to culinary school and
worked in restaurants but found her
passion in food writing and she rose to
the top serving as editor-in-chief of
Saveur magazine and authoring
best-selling cookbooks few years ago she
rediscovered her family's roots and
their recipes on a life-changing trip to
the old country and that led to her
latest release chiotti plates and
platters for sharing inspired by Italy
Stacey Adam Ando good morning and
welcome to the dish thank you so much
this is such a thrill what do we have so
these are just some of the dishes from
Piatti and the word itself is just
generally italian for plates but i was
inspired by the grand antipasti of italy
so we have a southern Italian spin on
the caprese salad
so obviously usually made with tomatoes
I made it with grilled peppers and I put
a little spice on there too we have a
radicchio salad which is one of my
favorite like sort of pleasantly bitter
greens from Italy made with some summer
corn and fennel fronds this gorgeous
platter in the center here is a spin on
chicken cutlets which are something that
every italian-american grows up with we
actually would eat them as kids with
ketchup a little more sophisticated you
could put out for guests so I did it
with roasted cranberries with garlic and
then over here we have a beautiful spin
on the crudité platter so I roasted the
vegetables so it's appropriate for
winter and fall and I finally a sort of
sweet or savory cornmeal cake made with
olive oils so that has little rosemary
some honey it can go either way and not
finally because of course the Negroni
small Yocto which is pretty bubbly
cousin of anaconda cheers cheers well
you know your life in the kitchen is in
the cookbook yeah it's very nice right
thank you as often you know you like
delving into other cultures but you know
this is about you it is personal yeah
yeah you know it's it's difficult as a
food writer you never really
want to sort of pigeonhole yourself into
one area or another there's so much of
the food world to explore but it was
just haunting me that I hadn't done
something about my Italian heritage and
so I'd been saving ideas for this book
for years just inspired by my travels
all over the country and then of course
dishes that I grew up eating from my
grandmother and great-grandparents and
mom and dad so it all kind of came
together into this you know collection
of recipes that I think are gonna really
inspire American cooks to put something
more fun out when people come over like
not cheese and crackers or chips and dip
but you can put this stuff out and it
can sit at room temperature and just be
a really friendly you know host spread
and it came together in part after
sitting down to this quote little lunch
what's this little well so we had always
talked about our distant relatives in
Italy and it was sort of just in passing
and my family and one year it just my
curiosity got the best of me and I said
to my grandparents like do you think I
could actually go meet our relatives in
Italy you know do you think you could
help me find them and I thought this was
going to take like months of searching
through Italian records or you know
digging them up and my grandfather got
me their phone numbers and addresses the
next day I took a solo trip to Italy and
met some distant cousins and aunts and
uncles and saw my great-grandfather's
house that he came from to the States
and it was so moving the most important
thing I've ever done
and basically my answer that day I had
sort of mediocre Italian and they said
oh we're gonna make you a little lunch
or that's what I thought they said yeah
so I stuffed myself there like veal and
pork meatballs and sausages and eggplant
parmigiana and all this beautiful stuff
and then they were like and here's lunch
and the pasta came out and swordfish and
cake and all this and I sort of had this
aha moment where I thought I could have
just been good with the antipasti like
this could be a trial and so it's how my
husband and I entertain now and along
those lines because it is it's not an
appetizer you can make meals of
appetizers what are some of the other we
see some of them here but what else did
it inspire in you well I think one thing
that American hosts kind of get uptight
about is that you know antipasto or
appetizer
are these like fussy little finger foods
and you're planning so much else in the
kitchen you don't really want to fuss
over anything so the the you know
Italians make everything look easy the
antipasti is the first example of that
because what they do is they just use
what's in season and what's local to
them and what's inexpensive and then
they just you know make it into a
beautiful platter or spread that people
can help themselves as we enjoy this
meal and as you sign the dish if you can
have it with anyone past or present who
would it be has to be my
great-grandparents and guys today is my
grandma Stella's birthday with us but I
know she's here with me happy birthday
she's a sad
Stacey out of mine though thank you
thank you so much it was an honor and
for more on Stacey in the dish head to
our website
here we go at CBS this morning
dot-com